hello welcome to a new video I'll be
doing some three minutes games on icc
game started oh that was quick um okay
so let's get going play a French here
yeah black has a huge choice should be 7
a-7 flexible move yeah and 35 is so the
real point of this so what happens now I
think I could take here so g5 was
designed to play g4 and undermine the
center the right immediately gave up the
center but of course I have a constant
problem here with this c5 move I mean g5
is some it's designed to down to attack
the center of it now the main point is
that my king is weakened so I don't know
where to where to put the king and he's
trying to open up the position
immediately not sure maybe I already did
something wrong looks dangerous already
maybe I tried to keep it closed but he
has f five at least yeah not sure
yeah I think I need to take don't think
there are any any good alternative so
now if i play Bishop Bishop to c 6 which
i would like to play you can capture the
f5
yeah it's a shaky position may be here
idea Queen c6 or Bishop 6 protecting b7
yeah this looks dangerous dangerous for
for my king it's on the open e file and
he has many natural attacking moves
Bishop f4 and centralizing the only good
thing about my position is the two
bishops which might be a factor later
but I need to reach the end game first
before I can do something with these
pieces okay at least he spend down quite
some time so what now no he always has
this Queenie five move if I play
something like Quincy 60 will play Queen
Queen 25 I could play a six then well I
need to to move a bit bit quicker here
too not that are not get into a huge
time problem in addition to the quite
doubtful position so what now Bishop to
have six and then it should be five okay
so
yeah hi morning yeah i'm eric i saw this
right after moving moving hmm this is
some yak will be a checkmater should be
six you might play am simply ripped you
wanna maybe it doesn't see it only hope
look to you one is over I think
maybe other mousse win as well but this
should win Ruby one I don't see a move
against this oh this was a bad start
okay any any kind of idea should be 57
us hanging no wow black resigns yeah
this was an accident g5 i'm not sure i
don't know that i don't know the theory
here what would I know this this is a
valid position I think of this is played
but what happens maybe taking is wrong
or whatever hmm I mean this is quite a
good piece and it helps him to play a
form no idea this was a pretty drastic
loss okay started let's hope it's better
in the second game so cones gambit okay
I'll go for the exchange he advised the
pure coming scam but exchange variation
with wooden Knight xt5 rugby one was
played because I wanted to prevent
Bishop to b4 ok so now Bishop to c4 or
to d3 it's always difficult to decide go
for see form ok now a typical ideas d 5
9 a-5 you can play ok
so maybe still okay so 95 I go here and
then it takes the f-35 this is the idea
and hopefully I got them some Taking
Chances want to go night f5 now or Queen
to h5 go into G form stuff like this
this d5 ed 5v5 is designed to block this
bishop on d5 so now your texts also e5
question is some okay well I had FB page
seven on this vertical also can i def
five that's difficult now so i could
play could actually play Bishop a one if
i want to preserve the serve this piece
hard to decide
okay i want the night IAM and if it
takes I might have this rook b3 idea
rugby 322 somewhere g3 h3 stuff like
that okay so what now I'm not sure is
threatening to take I mean let's say I
played this year if it takes Bishop
takes I have queen age five and rook to
e3 stuff like this this looks dangerous
okay want some counter play on the long
diagonal but he cannot play Queen d5
because this would would lose 297 Bishop
d5 might be an idea my money so should I
have a play here then Bishop d5 for half
the rook moves mmm interesting just a
way to defend so okay so i get the porno
back now maybe this was was a bad
decision practically because i want i
won't give made now and i'm down on time
position should be about equal maybe I
shouldn't have problems at least yeah
the apron I is playing is playing very
much I'm hoping to learn to use the time
advantage is playing instantly all the
time make sense of course now if a hard
time stopping this pawn yeah all right
white reside maybe I should have eaten
lunch before this okay so let's hope it
gets better game started okay so this
kind of opening at least I'm optimistic
that i won't lose in the opening f3 and
c3 okay I'll just develop until normal
squares
so what now I could take it to take also
keep the tension but after these two
games well where was some playing far
too slowly i want to be bit quicker here
so to at least prevent castling for move
a 6am has got the idea to play p5 Bishop
c4 maybe okay now is trying to do
something on the kingside this looks a
bit weird to me but maybe it's okay so
Bishop c4 94 ideas now ok on b3 I can
try to advance the pawn to a 4 we can we
can be three hear that take now this
night is improved greatly but not much
choice
how to play rock 37 and yea I'm guessing
this position somehow guess I just play
bad at lame ok so the end game should be
quite ok this April is a bit irritating
it might be might be weak at some sound
couldn't be 5 results an alternative so
if i take now the night will be under
root it's a most likely going anyway so
maybe night to be 5v5 g6 could be an
idea so yeah to go here catfish King d3
time morning hmm
yeah it's hard to do something here
now okay maitre d 4g 594 possible place
okay wants to prepared
yeah so think it's about equal I mean I
look worse but it's just not nothing
nothing special here don't think so now
here the question is my night maybe
travel to deform this is not bad wait a
three can I capture captures a 39 f 2 a2
a.m. on a 3 I can actually capture I'm a
pawn promotes if he recaptures oh that's
nice
well as I this was really bit a bit out
of the blue was nothing happening in
this game and then some of this chance
here turned up um I'm not sure that this
night h3y and so on was such a great
idea I think maybe you can play g5 firm
in one move anyway I mean without
without going it without going here on
HD okay so next game at least among the
score water so to say ok there's no
overall scoreboard here but two losses
at the start went to encouraging and
also played out far too far too slowly
in bed ok this also wasn't great but at
least the win game started oh ok I'm
pretty high rated towing grand awesome
so have the name in there check quickly
and David Smith's norden's building
whatever sir 2500 Grandmaster from
Australia but his son is living on the
Netherlands I think aunt it's also the
country flag him so at least down some
time of the yeas and the Netherlands
he's playing the Dutch league also okay
so um we got some pretty classical on
news of Indian set up and actually a
setup which supposed to be very good for
me so I'm curious um what is what is
doing here okay so can I go E for now ok
I can maybe click in this prep move
cannot go before
and now play you for actually before the
singing at the end and also at this
Queen f3 stuff okay so if I have no yeah
this is a position which is basically
winning for white I think but so need to
be exact here I mean I have a huge
attack going night to d6 and queen
coming up and so on so looks very nice
for me so Queens you for now so I think
I mean oh it's like going through candy
store here what i'ma do it over okay
let's let's check here first and f5 then
car lots of attractive moves threatening
or everything Bishop g5 night f7 okay
Bishop g5 then Bishop f6 and Queen it
and made yeah simply this is over Bishop
f6 if you move the Queen Bishop f6 King
takes between each project magazine yeah
no moose f6 takes over it just over yeah
at least I wasn't too optimistic about
saying that this would be winning
perfected one quickly yeah he's played
this quite quite strangely a crew I mean
this is supposed to be somewhat better
for white but but this is really a bit
too much because i have a very stable
center now and i will always get in this
f3 and you for stuff and this is just
just great for me the only alternative
that that he would have here I mean 96 /
basically the game the game happens so
I'm
if you were to take him of course I have
a brilliant center and let's say it
takes here then at least I can I can
maybe have something better even okay
let's say just what I saw in the game I
saw in the game this line and this is
quite nice already so what should you do
the room is hanging up seven and saying
and b5 also hanging so on cannot move
the rock maybe protect protect here then
I have quite quite a lot of interesting
ideas i mean at least i can take and
this is what I saw because this should
be it should be very good for me but
maybe there's even something better oops
maybe there's even something better okay
pretty nice game so let's request a new
one
yeah sometimes it even happens to very
strong players that day in those in
those quick time controls you want to
play quickly and just put put out some
quick moves and I mean this is just just
terrible for black I mean besides what I
played I can play for and black is
terrible and so on you just played too
quickly of course he knows that this is
this is bad if he thinks about it a
couple of seconds just please quickly
started okay so let's mix it up a bit
here I played the French and lost ya
okay so let's try the Sicilian ok so I'm
somewhat quite a line with c3 I couldn't
take because of Queen a4 check so yeah
this looks like a pretty um solid way
for white to play it should be somewhat
better I guess I didn't didn't play out
the most critical fashion here there
shouldn't be an opening where white
should should get some some some great
advantage or any advantage I think white
should be somewhat better here with the
space advantage okay so I could I could
actually take here to to worsen his pawn
structure but i'm not sure that i should
do it immediately i might place a move
that will help me okay so it looks like
he is he responded a bit by the double
porn and I did I don't think this would
would have been a huge issue for white
really
okay hmm I'm afraid that I might have I
need to exchange something to or to
adjust to myspace disadvantage this with
a white took on f3 if you have too many
pieces in the some slightly cramped
position it often happens that the
pieces among stand on each other's toes
so to say and it's often helpful to
exchange one pair of pieces now I think
the bishop has a nice copia from 27 and
the night has chances to get active here
on the cool side okay it looks like on
his planning Bishop h6 here which shall
make some sense but ok this is some
surprising
hmm I can play at least 93 to to get
this Bishop against night advantage Roxy
for between before everything son
looking fine okay I want to keep it
simple the Sun I think it just shows me
off of slight advantage at least I mean
maybe it's even more frightening on t3
now just winning a pawn and yeah I could
I could take now to to get a favorable
pawn structure I'm not sure that this is
the best though there might be other
mousse to to strengthen the position
look to see for for instance timing not
sure I should have decided to squeaker I
mean the ship's III was just a pretty
clear advantage I mean maybe it's it's
not clear in the sense of that I'm not
Lots that I'm better by uture margin but
it would have been a simple decision
okay this one's a porn
I don't clear see any compensation here
rook be one I can even grab some another
porn you cannot know we cannot do setups
up some pin or something okay so yeah
but now this this something like Quincy
to our queen yeah Quincy to its may be
threatened so let's prevent this okay do
I even have the time to move my porn
maybe and then retreat the bishop
finally the air mission accomplished two
points up Roxy two would be my next move
yeah looks nice now but I need to speed
up of course played really slowly I hope
t3 the mount you want to flick in a
quick move you overlooked something yeah
i saw that i lose the exchange but this
looks very nice so okay premium of time
quite resign yeah okay oh this was was
pretty nice actually I think looked like
pretty pretty clean victory alright so
next game so after this shaky start I
managed to get I think for three wins
over ok against drama dice international
master maybe look let's look at the
judges bahaha i always forget what it is
played him so often right so so ok very
real line a with a six but white can can
play a for it's no big deal so we
transpose into some some benoni here
with a 6 a-4 inserted you have no idea
what this means if there's anything any
special point to this I think these
moves are inserted off in any way ok I'm
setting up the pretty much the standard
set up against the Benoni nowadays with
h3 Bishop d3 this Bishop g5 is a slide
twist though night h7 ok this might
prepare 95 or maybe g5 ok I don't see
any reason to not provoke g5 it looks am
it is weakening after all ok
so what now look cookie one or something
should an should actually retreat here
maybe not so bad this kind of setup I
had in mind all right okay yeah opens it
up but i have f FOIA also question is
should I player for now I take first I
think I cannot layer for immediately it
takes h6 under attack instantly and I
mean what-what else okay great okay it
can play now g6 okay I didn't really
appreciate this maybe logistics was an
idea very interesting if i just take
here if he retakes i take on g fiber
window in material right so i can take
care what some trick or just win win the
special lap resigned okay well to be
honest i think it was pretty pretty bad
anyway but maybe yam the computer likes
white but nothing special not f6 it
wants to play Queen to have six it wants
to play yeah makes sense covers h six
and five it's a bit unnatural to put the
Queen on the FO bit computer ish this
move but ok you need to cover h-60 you
cannot cannot sec this pawn I was
thinking actually instead of taking
maybe maybe here would be an idea it
because on here black can
it's in a position like this just to
just to show the idea Black has has this
this kind of idea a quad I don't need to
recapture it i just wanted to show the
the idea so of course it's very very
tricky tricky business okay um
interesting name okay mussing and i
played him before and I think I lost you
kind of forgot what was happening here
not sure this is a good sign but I
played him before today hi I remember I
remember this was this this this game
with this night XD fine okay I really
like my position and I just need to do
this quicker
okay yeah he's amazingly willing to
repeat this I mean I thought I was
really really doing well okay but it's
strange move Bishop before this is so
important okay
really boss can't believe this really
hmm ok so
well I'm a bit stunned that he tries to
the things you can afford this but
alright okay i won't cover the look or
move the rook okay
check
I mean isn't this dangerous with hmm e
69 f5 yeah things early six he might he
might take I don't see a made yet it
looks like utter crap but I don't see a
maid
check check
i takes 26 now
what is Karrueche 80
create on hard to believe but I think
it's holding check
check
unbelievable I think this was not just
check mate and some guy yeah I didn't
see it that you got two out of two out
of this complete crap is just a joke but
it's a I mean the joke on my on my costs
off to say I should have just bought
this what the heck ok I can of course
resign quite resigned all right this is
just not absolutely cannot believe this
okay so um okay let's see I mean ok I
can
our queen h5 has made all right here
it's really check media made in five oh
man and it's not it's not too too
difficult actually let's see here right
it's dead simple I mean Quincy for looks
nice and all but this is over
threatening 97 Queen h7 mate and what is
he doing let's say it is here so I can
just take I mean okay can play this but
I'm just winning and also this move f7
and so on haha mischance very much miss
chance yeah well it's always a bit
frustrating to lose again smooth like a
five and and those night okay but it's
it's my own fault i need to play i need
to punish this correctly queen age five
is just it's just better I mean you
always at least and I think it's always
very tempting in this is this this kind
of stuff here it was very tempted that
that this would would help me a lot but
the computer is not seeing a win here it
doesn't find a win at once he wants to
play I mean I have pretty good
compensation but it doesn't see a win
here which is pretty pretty surprising
for my taste I've got everything on the
king and well maybe it it doesn't see it
immediately could you demonstrate rook
takes rook takes him
then deform yeah this is logical to to
get this bishop into play and to break
break the long diagonal here this
diagonal not once all 86 and gives black
a pretty and substantial advantage after
Bishop g5 so I really need to go queen
age five amazing that Queen I mean this
is better you can it's technically yeah
but it's pretty pretty clear after
looking at this but that Queen g4 was
really really bad as sound surprising
okay so let's request another game if I
got to get this guy again that he plays
the radiation again oh man I really need
to win this motive would be very
frustrated frustrating if it would do if
you would lose three times okay so
waiting for fun new game the video is
close to 40 minutes already and usually
think that 45 minutes is a good game
good time so this would be the last game
now so what do you play play this is so
you and upright the flare French what
else can I do it can play stuff like
this for China of our change sort of
modern Piltz whatever Oh cue plays g4
interesting ok I'll fianchetto this is
bishop
maybe prepare see 5 or not maybe I will
definitely play a play see 5 so the
question is is h5 as this move I should
pay attention to maybe I should but not
too clear
hmm I could play h5 myself but okay if
it takes I might take with the bishop
it's a bit unusual looking but the night
f6 this movie not so bad so Knight f6 no
mmm this is just hanging Jesus Christ
what am i doing I need to take first of
course Wow okay definitely a last game
for the session and then I'll go grab
some lunch okay um is there some way to
to fight you hmm not really okay okay i
play a couple of moves maybe he's doing
something really really stupid but it's
just just very bad pieces of pieces of
peace
okay so maybe I can go root leaf I for
some some silly stuff all right okay
it's a maybe I can can get in some silly
tricks here night to a 42 c 3 our stuff
like this check
he just ignores that I'm that I'm
threatening a tomb maybe he can but ok
let's take here getting a bit a bit
interesting now minced along with a
piece down but hmm
yeah it's still bad I can just take or
give this check here
how to understand those moves but thou
if it's still a piece but somewhere i'm
still alive at least i'm not mated or
something okay close the position up a
bit covering with moroccan mcqueen down
on time the position is so still bad but
check check hi this is very unlucky this
996s checkmate he really did everything
to get me back into the game so reform
even after blundering this piece it
wasn't entirely clear check check yeah i
should resign now it really block or the
compound yeah okay or just for a long
time hey i'm not sure i mean what did
this I've got what I've got two points
yeah two pawns but it's it's not it's
not entirely clear i mean fo for the
computer it is clear yeah maybe but it
was worth much more than I deserved
after after I just blundered this year
in one move I just I just forgot to take
all right okay some some entertaining
games have made some pretty
pretty dreadful for mistakes but I
thought it was entertaining and maybe
I'm interesting in some points yeah
thanks for watching and talk to you soon
on a new video